♪ ♪
>> WE WILL TURN OUR GRIEF INTO
ACTION.
WE HAVE TO HAVE ACTION.
THIS INCLUDES ALONG WELL TRAINED
AND CERTIFIED SCHOOL PERSONNEL
TO CARRY CONCEALED FIREARM.
BUMP STOCKS, I AM WRITING THAT
OUT MYSELF.
I DON'T CARE IF CONGRESS DOESN'T
OR NOT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE NRA.
THEY ARE ON OUR SIDE.
HALF OF YOU ARE SO AFRAID OF THE
NRA.
THERE IS NOTHING TO BE AFRAID
OF.
WE MUST PURSUE COMMON SENSE
MEASURES THAT PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS WHILE
KEEPING GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO POSE A THREAT TO
THEMSELVES AND TO OTHERS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO START
TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE FOLKS IN THIS ROOM CLOSE TO
THEIR INSTITUTIONS.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT PRE
>> Bret: PRESIDENT PRI
>> Bret: PRESIDENT PRT
>> Bret: PRESIDENT PRU
>> Bret: PRESIDENT PRP
TALKING WITH GOVERNORS TODAY.
SCHOOL SAFETY AND GUNS.
THIS AS A NEW POLL OUT FROM USA
TODAY, MOST RECENT SAYING SHOULD
SCHOOLS BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
METAL DETECTORS AT POINT OF
ENTRY.
62-27.
ARMED POLICE OFFICER ON SITE.
58%.
WHEN IT COMES TO CURBING MASS
SHOOTINGS, WHICH IS MORE
IMPORTANT?
YOU SEE THE BREAKDOWN.
RESTRICTING ACCESS TO GUNS,
IMPROVING MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
BOTH, A LOT OF TALK A LOT
DIFFERENT POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS ON
SCHOOL SAFETY.
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
STEPHEN HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF
FOR "THE WEEKLY STANDARD."
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
AND DAN BALZ, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
CONGRESS SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO PUT A LEGISLATIVE PACKAGING.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT THE NRA AND YOU
SHOULDN'T BE WORRIED ABOUT IT,
DO YOU THINK THERE'S A CHANCE
SOMETHING MIGHT COME TOGETHER?
>> I THINK IT'S STILL GOING TO
BE DIFFICULT.
I THINK THEY ARE STILL MILES
APART ON SOME OF THE ISSUES.
I THINK IT WILL BE PARTLY
DETERMINED BY HOW MUCH PEOPLE
TRY TO DO.
IF THEY CAN GO LEANER AND
SIMPLER, MAYBE THEY CAN DO
SOMETHING ON BACKGROUND CHECKS
BUT BEYOND THAT, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO.
THESE STANDOFFS HAVE EXISTED FOR
A LONG TIME.
THE NRA HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN BLOCKING EFFORTS IN THE PAST
AFTER OTHER SHOOTINGS.
I THINK A LOT ABOUT WHAT TO DO
WITH WHAT ROLE THE PRESIDENT
CHOOSES TO PLAN HOW EFFECTIVE HE
IS.
>> Bret: APPARENTLY HAD LUNCH
AT THE WHITE HOUSE WITH SOME NRA
LEADERSHIP, INCLUDING WAYNE
LaPIERRE AND OTHERS.
MOLLIE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING WE ARE EVEN
TALKING ABOUT GUN CONTROL AS A
RESPONSE TO SOMETHING WHERE THE
MORE WE LEARN ABOUT IT, WE ARE
LEARNING ABOUT A SERIES OF EPIC,
CATASTROPHIC FAILURES.
THE SCHOOL, THE FBI, THE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER, THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT BRING DOZENS OF TIMES
BEING TOLD ABOUT THIS PERSON AND
DOING NOTHING.
THE SHOOTER AND HIMSELF NOTIFIED
AUTHORITIES HE WAS A THREAT AND
NOTHING WAS DONE.
THE IDEA THAT WE HAD RESPOND TO
THE STORY BY RESTRICTING MOM
THE STORY BY RESTRICTING MOM   -
LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN'S TO BEAR
ARMS.
>> Bret: GOVERNOR SCOTT AND
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THIS
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY, COUPLE OUTSIDE
THE SCHOOL AND THE WARNINGS
MISSED.
>> THE LOCAL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT, THEY'VE GOT TO
BECOME FULLY TRANSPARENT.
WE HAVE TO DO A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
WHOEVER DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB HAVE
>> I GOT TO WATCH SOME DEPUTY
SHERIFFS PERFORMING THIS
WEEKEND.
THEY WEREN'T EXACTLY MEDAL OF
HONOR WINNERS.
>> I CAN ONLY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I KNEW
ABOUT.
I EXERCISED MY DUE DILIGENCE.
I'VE GIVEN AMAZING LEADERSHIP TO
THIS AGENCY.
OF COURSE I WON'T RESIGN.
>> Bret: THERE ARE CALLS NOW,
INCLUDING THE FLORIDA HOUSE
SPEAKER, FOR THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF TO RESIGN.
WHAT ABOUT THIS, STEVE?
>> HE HAS NOT GIVEN AMAZING
LEADERSHIP.
HE'S BEEN PRETTY MUCH THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT OF A LEADER IN A TIME OF
CRISIS.
THERE WERE FAILURES AGAIN AND
AGAIN, NOT JUST IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES, NOT JUST IN THE HEAT OF
THE MOMENT, BUT GOING BACK
MONTHS.
I THINK HIS DEPARTMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT GUN CONTROL IS
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TALKING ABOUT GUN CONTROL.
I THINK DAN IS RIGHT.
A LOT OF WHAT HAPPENS FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD WILL DEPEND ON HOW
MUCH PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO
EXPEND POLITICAL CAPITAL TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN.
NOW, HE SAID HE IS WORKING ON
BUMP STOCKS.
HE DOESN'T CARE IF THEY DO IT
LEGISLATIVELY.
HE'S HAPPY TO DO IT
ADMINISTRATIVELY.
THERE ARE TWO OTHER PLACES HE
TALKED ABOUT MAKING CHANGES.
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND THE AGE TO
PURCHASE ON LONG GUNS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SEEMS TO COME IN
SARAH SANDERS PRESS BRIEFING,
TAKING A SMALL STEP BACK.
THE PRESIDENT, WHILE HE SAID
THIS, STILL BEING DISCUSSED.
PART OF A BROADER DISCUSSION.
DOES THAT MEAN THE WHITE HOUSE
IS ACTUALLY STOPPING BACK --
STEPPING BACK OR THEY ARE MAKIN
STEPPING BACK OR THEY ARE MAKINA
TACTICAL PLAY?
>> Bret: A NUMBER OF GOVERNORS
STEPPED UP, SAID A COUPLE, SAID
THEY DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH TEACHERS BEING ARMED,
INCLUDING WASHINGTON'S GOVERNOR.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE SUGGESTED
ARMING OUR TEACHERS.
>> NO, NO, NO.
NOT YOUR TEACHERS.
ARMING A SMALL PORTION THAT ARE
VERY GUN ADAPT THE TRULY KNOW
HOW TO HANDLE.
IT WOULD BE A VERY SMALL GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY GUN
ADAPT.
>> I HAVE LISTENED TO
FIRST GRADE TEACHERS WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE PACKING PISTOLS.
I'VE LISTENED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO TRAIN TEACHERS AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHICH TAKES
ABOUT SIX MONTHS.
I SUGGEST WE NEED A LITTLE LESS
TWEETING AND MORE LISTING.
>> Bret: DAN, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
IS IT GAINING TRACTION OR TAKING
AWAY?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING BE A
STATE-BY-STATE THING.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF GOVERNORS.
I'VE BEEN COVERING THE GOVERNORS
ALL WE CAN.
IN TALKING TO THEM, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF GOVERNORS IN BOTH
PARTIES UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
IDEA.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
SOME ARE ALREADY DOING IT.
>> WE TALKED WITH
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IN TEXAS ABOUT
WHAT THEY'VE DONE AND I THINK
THEY SAID ALMOST A FIFTH OF THE
SCHOOLS HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ARMED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IN PART
WILL HAVE TO DO WITH THE CULTURE
OF EACH OF THOSE STATES.
THE CULTURE OF THE USE OF GUNS
AND HOW COMFORTABLE PEOPLE ARE
WITH IT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF GOVERNORS
WHO SAY, INCLUDING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS, ADDING GUNS TO THIS
ENVIRONMENT IS NOT WHAT THEY
WANT TO SEE IN SCHOOLS.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT GOES FORWARD.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF CULTURE,
I WANT TO PLAY ONE MORE
SOUND BITE.
THIS IS FROM KENTUCKY'S